where we left off in the last video we
were in the year 656 and the third
khalaf with ma Norris maan is
assassinated and Ali is chosen to be
caliph and remember she has believed
that Ali should have been khalaf
immediately after the death of Muhammad
and they cite the events of gather come
as evidence that that is what Muhammad
intended but alie becomes caliph in 656
but this sparks what is called the first
fitna or the first Muslim civil war
because it's mon has a fellow member of
the Umayyad clan you might clan there
also Quraish just like Muhammad's clan
Hashem are also Croatian and both Mon
family member malawi ax it was has been
governor of Damascus since the time of
the Caliph Omer and when ass maan is
assassinated malawi ax is not happy and
when Ali comes to power he thinks that
Ali is not making a solid effort to put
the assassins to justice and he refuses
to to pledge his allegiance to Ali as
the Caliph
now the other context here is that
mu'awiya is has already built a
significant military force and that
force is becoming stronger and stronger
and stronger and so this leads to a lot
of tension voilá wants Ali to bring the
assassins of Othman to justice and Ali
wants mu'awiya to pledge allegiance to
him who is now khalaf now just for a
little bit extra context Ali also
decides to move the capital of the
Caliphate to Kufa which is in modern-day
Iraq now things are getting increasingly
tense and this is where we have Aisha
entering into the picture and we talk
about Aisha in the previous video she is
one of Muhammad's wives married at a
very young age and she is considered a
very strong figure in her
the Aslam so she leads a delegation
really an army in order to convince Ali
to bring the assassins of Oman to
justice they meet in Basra once again in
modern-day Iraq and while they are
talking about or negotiating what Ali
needs to do some of Ali's followers as
the narrative goes or a little bit more
extreme and really didn't want a peace
brokered between Malaya and Ali and so
they attack and that what leads to what
is known as the Battle of the camel
which is depicted here named after Isis
camel and it becomes a very bloody
battle Aisha is really one of the
leaders in this battle once again you
could imagine a very very strong figure
in early Islam but Ali's forces are
victorious and they send Asia back home
and then she goes into something of a
political retirement and it is somewhat
inconclusive but then that leads later
on to what is known as the Battle of
Siffin the Battle of the camel was in
656 the Battle of Siffin
is in 657 and in this situation you once
again have a delegation or really an
army on the side of Ali meeting an army
directly now with malaria at Siffin and
once again they are they are not
fighting for roughly a hundred days they
want to negotiate something but some of
the more ardent followers of Ali don't
want any form of peace with malaria
so they attack Malawi's army and you
have a very bloody battle that ensues
now both sides don't want all of this
bloodshed in this burgeoning Muslim
community so they decide to they decide
to let it be decided by arbitration
now the arbitration according to the
accounts that I've looked at say that
they decide that neither Ally or Mallya
should be callous and that it should be
an election from the Muslim community
now Ali refuses this and what's
interesting about this is the accounts
I've seen is those same zealous folks
who you could say instigated the Battle
of Siffin and the Battle of the camel
during this Muslim civil war they're no
longer trusting Ali that he can protect
them that he is the strong leader they
need and so they are the ones that then
this decide to assassinate and are
successful in assassinating Ali so after
the assassination of Ali his son Hasan
comes to power officially as the calais
based in Kufa but remember you have this
very powerful leader in mu'awiya with a
very significant military leading or in
control of the Levant and the governor
of Syria and so they enter into a treaty
clearly Hasan sees the writing on the
wall he can't really fight mallya by
force he really doesn't have strong
control really much further than this
region around Kufa so he gets into a
treaty with Malawi where he gives
control of the Caliphate to Malawi and
according to that treaty as long as
Malawi ax allows the next column after
his death to be based on some form of an
election let the Islamic world choose
the successor afterwards but then later
Hasan he goes into something of
retirement he dies in his mid 40s in
some accounts say that he was
assassinated poisoned by his wife may be
due to the Amaya's who didn't want him
around and then in 680 mu'awiya dies now
according to the treaty between mahalia
and Hasan it should have been some form
of an election there but Malawi ax says
or before his death he makes yahzee
the successor and so Hussein who is
another son of Ali Hasan younger brother
and by this point Hassan is dead he says
hey this is a breach of the Treaty and
does not pledge his allegiance to yah
Sid but there's a group in Kufa who say
hey we will support you and so Hussein
goes to Kufa but on the way there and
he's with his family when Yas it catches
wind of this he sends an army to stop
them and yah seeds interest is
essentially to eliminate Hussein and his
family so that you don't have any other
legitimate claimants to the Caliphate
especially because remember Hussein is a
living descendant of Muhammad and so you
then have this event where Aziz forces
intercept Hussein's Caravan in Karbala
and this is known in the Shia tradition
as the tragedy of Karbala because at
Karbala you have Hussein's family gets
massacred there's an account that his
six month old son is beheaded and killed
along with Hussein and so this becomes
the defining event of the Shia tradition
the tragedy of Karbala we've already
talked their belief that Ali should have
been the Caliph from the beginning but
now you have the you have yas it
purported khalaf who murders who kills
off according to Shia tradition a
significant member of Muhammad's family
and does this in bloody bloody fashion
and so even to this day a significant
part of the Shia tradition is mourning
what happens at the Battle of Karbala
and this is not a part of the Sunni
tradition the Sunni tradition views this
as a tragedy as an unfortunate event but
they do not view this as a significant
part of their theology and also as part
of Shia tradition and theology Battle of
Karbala is
is the is the determining event the
thing that she has mourn in their
religious faith and they also believe
that the leadership of the community
should be buy-in moms who are descendant
of Muhammad which is not believed by the
Sunnis